اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من الجليل الاعلى
اهلا بكم بلينكن يقول ان رد حماس يتيح
مجالا للتوصل الى اتفاق نتنياهو يؤكد ان
المفاوضات مستمره وان الحرب ستتواصل ووفد
من حركه حماس في القاهره للمشاركه في
مباحثات برعايه قطريه مصريه وجانتس يعتبر
ان الاولويه الان هي ايجاد طريقه لاستعاده
الرهائن في غزه
الجيش الاسرائيلي يسحب فرقه وثلاثه الويه
من مناطق في القطاع وكتيبه من خانيونس
ويقول ان
54 جنديا اصيبوا بنيران صديقه منذ بدء
الاجتياح البري لغزه سرايا القدس تقول
انها هاجمت تجمعا للجنود بصاروخ موجه في
المحافظه الوسطى وقصف اسرائيلي متواصل
وكثيف لاحياء سكنيه في في مناطق عده من
قطاع غزه وخاصه مخيمات النازحين في
رفح 130 شهيدا خلال 24 ساعه شهداء في قصف
اسرائيلي على مجمع الشفاء الطبي في غزه
وقوات الاحتلال تحكم حصارها على مستشفى
ناصر وسط مخاطر تهدد حياه مئات المرضى
والاف النازحين في
المجمع وفي الضفه الغربيه شهداء برصاص
الاحتلال في مواجهات اثناء اقتحام مخيم
نور شمس بطول كرم وقوات الاحتلال تطلق
النار على فلسطيني غرب نابلس وتمنع طواقم
الاسعاف من انقاذه ومستوطنون يهاجمون
سيارات فلسطينيه في قريه دير شرف شمالي
نابلس الى
اللقاء